Prince area and Megan Marco just
celebrating their one-year wedding
anniversary can you believe it a
nischelle Turner is back with us from
London and leecy we love how they
commemorated the occasion Oh Nance you
know I love love so when Harry and Megan
shared never before seen photos of their
fairytale I Do's we were all in the
couple celebrated their first wedding
anniversary yesterday posting these
intimate photos with the sweet detail
the pics are set against the music of
the kingdom choir who performed at st.
George's Chapel when Megan and Harry
said I do now a new lifetime TV movie
Harry and Megan becoming royal recreates
the couple's special day Tiffany Smith
is Megan Charley field is Harry the day
we put the dress on and the tiara I was
so overwhelmed because I was looking in
the mirror oh my gosh I really do look a
lot like her I remember coming on
Saturday night whoa that's like the most
I've ever seen you look like Megan this
follow up to the network's first Harry
and Megan movie chronicles the couple's
first year of marriage and takes some
creative license with what might have
happened behind closed doors I'm so
sorry for all of the family drama oh
darling don't fret those things have
happened you'd see in a side note there
are some real royal ties in this TV
movie Charles Shaughnessy who plays
Prince Charles is a baron in real life
my dad grew up at court I mean they had
apartments it's and James's and Windsor
Castle and he grew up with the Princess
Elizabeth for Tiffany the biggest
compliment in becoming Megan came at
Kensington Palace when she was out on a
run someone else comes up and we'll take
excuse me are you Megan Markel and I
started laughing because I was just like
well no I'm not but it would be amazing
if she was like I'm gonna go for a run
and in front of my house and be like can
you take that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]